well good evening from London welcome to
Petersburg Town Center I'm back from New
York but we're still here and we're
still live here 15 year old in Britain
who's convicted a murder will
automatically be given a life sentence a
15 year old can also apply to join the
armed forces and begin serving in the
next year and they'll also better get
married and start paying taxes in
Scotland the new Trans Rights bill
allows 15 year olds to begin the
life-changing process of altering their
gender with no medical diagnosis anyone
who criticized that law was scolded as a
bigger until the 15 year olds are
perfectly capable of making adult
decisions so what about the decision to
leave your home in East London and join
an Islamic death cult in Syria well
shamima begum made that decision when
she was 15. she left the country that
raised her cared for and educated her to
marry a murderer she joined an Islamic
death cult bent on destroying Western
Civilization through rape and torture
beheading people setting fire to them
several years later when a suicide
bomber killed 22 at an Ariana Grande
concert in Manchester she said this
it's a two-way thing really
because women and children aren't being
killed back in the Islamic State right
now
and it's kind of retaliation like the
their justification was that it was
retaliation so I thought okay that is a
Fed justification
a fair justification that children
who were most of the victims watching a
pop concert were blown to pieces in one
of Britain's most harrowing Terror
attacks
begum also told the times newspapers are
seeing decapitated heads in bins quotes
didn't phase her
the most damningly of all perhaps she
said this
yeah I will admit I was the one that
made the choice
even though I was only 15 years old I
did have I I do have like I could make
my own decisions back there I do have
the like mentality to make my own
decision that I did leave on my own
knowing that
begum's Defenders say she's an innocent
child who was groomed that's not how she
sees it though so why should we in
recent years begums attempted to
reinvent herself she has Savvy advisors
and a battery of legal Minds fighting
her case in the UK at vast expense
she started on a BBC podcast and the
headscar's been replaced by a cap and
sunglasses a little more Tick-Tock than
terrorist state
I think I could very much help you in
your fight against terrorism because
you clearly don't know what you're doing
yeah we don't need any help from you
thanks in our fight against terrorism
begum was rightly stripped of her
British citizenship in 2019 leaving her
languishing in a Syrian refugee camp
last weekend Court upheld that decision
but now the UK's own terrorism Watchdog
Jonathan Hall KC says we should bring
her back
I don't agree other countries including
the U.S Canada and France do this
differently they prefer their homegrown
terrorists to sit in their jails and be
permanently monitored at vast taxpayers
expense but I think Britain made the
right call on this she was our problem
but she chose not to be our problem
anymore
well joining me now is criminal defense
lawyer and human rights campaigner Alma
Anwar and former U.S ambassador Peter
Galbraith well welcome to both of you
so let me start with you uh Amar amoir I
just can't find it in me to see a
credible reason why we should let
shamima begum back given that she also
had Bangladeshi citizenship they may
have renounced it but that's not our
problem
she seems to me to be a very cynical
young woman who actually knew exactly
what she was doing I've got four kids
three of them were all been through
their young teens I'm 15 they know what
they're doing she knew exactly what she
was doing when she got on her path to
Syria she married an Isis fighter who
was committing Terror atrocities she had
three children who all sadly died with
this monster she could see her seven
head and a bin and not be phased by it
she thought the Manchester terror attack
was justified that was the logic of the
death cult she was with I just don't see
why we should be spending a huge amount
more of taxpayer money on top of the
legal bills we've already had to face to
to fight this case I'm just putting her
here somewhere well the first thing I'd
say is uh I don't believe that people
that we accuse of terrorism who are
British citizens should be dumped in
other countries that didn't want it the
Syrian people the Kurdish people the
Iraqi people suffered enough with
foreign Fighters come to their land
that's the first thing I would say the
second issue of course Pierce is that
this was an individual at the age of 15
has been accepted by the courts was
groomed was radicalized was then
trafficked and a victim of child
exploitation she was married off she's
not she's not a victim let me finish
she's not a victim she's 15 years old
that you don't get you don't have a
child doesn't get to consent a 15 year
old doesn't get to consent to have sex
and to be married to somebody I was an
adult if the sturgeon had her away in
Scotland she could be talking about
Jimmy my begum you can try and divert
the issue I'm trying to answer no I'm
just saying I'm saying I'm just saying
I'm interested are you saying no no 15
year old has a right of consent and
that's not that's child exploitation
actually what I sleep under the law what
I'm saying is we've literally just had
this debate in Scotland where we were
all assured a 15 year old
hang on I'm talking about a 15 year
old's right to give consent about
life-changing things in their life about
child sexual exploitation a 15 year old
under the law of this country does not
have the ability to give consent to be
married off to a man okay and to have
sex with them those people and I agree
with you what about Isis
impregnated by somebody's groomed and
write the class that's the first thing I
don't know what went on ahead I don't
have any truck with her ideas with that
Isis and surprising Center we've heard
her ideas exactly and I've got no truck
with them because as far as an Isis is a
perverted death call right the first
thing I would say is why should Syria
why should Kurdistan why should Iraq
have to put up with British Fighters the
second issue you raised about
citizenship is this because it seems to
me as though there's two classes of
citizenship in this country first of all
if she was if her name was Sharon she
was white from Manchester there's no way
her citizenship would be ripped away the
second issue is about you said about
having a Bangladeshi citizenship well
actually no because like for himself I
was born and brought up in this country
but up by The Quirk of Fate
um I could have my citizenship stripped
because my parents happened to be of
Pakistani origin that's not acceptable
because Bangladesh said at the age of 19
that they were evoking it because she
has never been to Bangladesh that's the
other part of it living in a camp of
twenty thousand Isis Fighters you've
already mentioned that um America
Germany and other countries I have taken
back
um terrorist Fighters and the the other
issue I have is this because it wasn't
just 15 euros there was children who
were younger than that who were being
groomed and trafficked by a perverted
difficult sexually trafficked sexual
agreement I would want those like
shamima begun who tore up the social
contract with this country and went to
join Isis who if they want to come back
to this country then the first demand
should be share the information provide
us the details of those who have gone
into the Shadows who will still be
recruiting who will still be trafficking
and who still want to carry out tax in
this country but also Abode but we
should not under the international law
wash our hands of those individuals who
happen to be British because you would
have been the first of course
to turn around say the likes of Abu
hanza and terrorist preachers and
radical extremists should be deported
back to their country of origin yet for
some reason because you happen to have a
brown skin because you have to be Shima
begum that we shouldn't take
responsibility there's nothing to do
with a skin color I just think she's a
disgusting disgusting piece of work who
made her Isis bride babe well if you
haven't actually stayed out there for
many years having repeated children who
died in appalling circumstances she's
shown absolutely
absolutely no sign of real remorse to me
died because
decided to strip her obviously you're
blaming that we ripped the British Home
Secretary I am because such actions that
she made herself what that child was
innocent the child was innocent and
didn't deserve to die if you have
evidence this is what I believe in this
country we don't we don't rule we don't
have the rule of law which is dictated
by opinion polls by a Revenge mob or
retribution what we have is the rule of
law and if we have evidence of citizens
British citizen who commits crimes you
can't just bring them back investigate
cute and send them to prison that's what
you do it's because we have the rule of
law that the rule of law has now been
applied to her and it has reaffirmed
that decision by Sanji Javid that she
shouldn't be allowed back into the
country you just talked about wanting
the rule of law to be at place the rule
of law has literally been implemented
the rule of law it was done on a
administrative process under three panel
the judges actually said that they had
grave concerns because she was
expectation they had to deal with it on
an administrative project hang on they
upheld the decision therefore the rule
of law has actually been carried out
which is what you wanted
well you were talking about Scotland
earlier on the law has changed
constantly in this country because of a
public debate homosexuality of the same
sex marriage used to be illegal so what
you're saying is do you believe so
you're saying that do you believe John
do you think the rule of law that
literally has just been upheld you're
the ones
decriminalizing homosexuality back in
the 60s you are the one who organized
the debate tonight
it was your choice no you asked a
question I know I answered that you know
you you cited the rule of laws being
incredibly important I just said to you
the rule of law is literally just been
implemented and it said she can't come
back